i don't know how famous darren brown is
outside of the uk
right now i'm probably not so much i've
never heard darren brown oh my god some
of the [ __ ] this man did was crazy
so his favorite thing that he's ever
done so dan brown is a magician from the
uk
he's he's he's a magician that basically
but he's more like a mental magician
mentalist
i'm not even like it's [ __ ] about the
word mentalist this makes
this makes it sound fake this man is
just one of a kind yeah yes man he's
like he's he's a showman he says like
everything i do
is like there's it's it's like not not
so much that it's fake but like it's
there is like magic involved he doesn't
claim to be have special powers or
something like that he just claims to
understand psychology
and plays on that right yeah so there's
this one tv show that you did and it is
literally my favorite and it's so
big brain this whole thing so i i'll
spoil the end of it so i'll warn you i'm
going to do that but i'll spoil it for
you because it's but
it's still cool either way if you watch
it so what happens is this tv show
starts and you're following the
perspective of this one woman and i know
this one
so basically what happens is that um so
the show is is that he
basically he knows which horse is going
to win in these horse races right so
the the exact name of the special is
called the system
so the way he markets it is that he has
a system
that can 100 predict which horse is
going to win in a horse race
and so it's like this this middle-aged
woman and you know we follow her
he calls her up he's like listen bet on
this horse go now so she goes and she
bets on it and the cameras are following
her
she bets on it she wins right it's like
oh [ __ ] okay
and then he rings her up again he's like
right now put all of your money
on this horse now then like then a week
later yeah and she puts
she puts all the money on it she wins
again right it's like what the [ __ ] is
how is he doing this
yeah this is legit like whole like this
is a fully legitimate yeah like
it's like a public uh gambling that
anyone can battle right
right it's a real horse yeah he gives
him the money doesn't he he gives them a
thousand pounds right
i think i can't remember it's been a
while but i i do
no i don't think he gives him any money
does he know well so anyway
she wins and then it happens again and
he's like all right now bet again
all the money on this horse she does it
again and she wins
right and i think it's one more time
he's like all right now this is the
final one bet all of your money on this
again
and she wins and you're like what the
[ __ ] is going on yeah
he's literally guessing and then he
reveals right and as the episode ends
that like
he's literally done like a tournament
bracket of like
every single race there's nine horses so
every single race
he's literally found nine people and
told them to bet
on the different horses he's literally
gone through and done like a giant like
hundreds of
races so it's like a pyramid so like at
the beginning he started with like
thousands of
thousands of contestants and he said you
know um
i i you know he didn't reveal who his
identity was he was just like an
anonymous tip
and so you know part of like a certain
round people won they got eliminated
he gave him a refund and then he went up
to the next bracket and then he kept
he basically kept enough of a group of
people to make sure there was
at least one point and it's so simple
yeah it's so cool but when you're
following
this story in her perspective it seems
like like literal magic yeah yeah yeah
because
all he was trying the message he was
trying to say was like
don't forget about perspective just
because you are winning doesn't mean
that
like doesn't mean like there's a magical
system or something like that
it's it's all to do with probability
that sounds right up my alley dude
he's literally a [ __ ] junior yeah his
shows are amazing and like he did one
where
he's done so many questions like i think
one of my favorite ones is like the ones
where
he actually he actually fakes a zombie
apocalypse
right oh that sounds familiar yeah i
might have seen that yeah yeah
so basically he takes us he takes this
one guy right
um so how he gets people on the special
is that people apply to be honest
specials right right
but he doesn't tell anyone that's they
you know he didn't tell anyone that
they've succeeded right so he gets
thousands and thousands of applicants
and he chooses one out one out of
everyone
so he takes this guy and he puts he
basically
um hypnotizes him so he like passes out
and he wakes up in this like abandoned
hospital right right and you know it's
it's
it's basically just this guy going
through a zombie apocalypse
except the truman show right because
they get everyone around him to act
right is that there's a zombie
apocalypse yeah yeah this guy literally
believes that there's like zombie
apocalypse i think this is on i think
it's on netflix as well so you can
actually watch this on there
there's another one where he sees if he
can convince someone to commit murder
jesus like fake murder right he sets up
the situation
that one's not as good as his other ones
but like they all vary in quality but
you're definitely gonna have an
experience like you definitely can't
find anything like it what's the name of
the show again just type in darren brown
darren darren darren brown
but he's he's done a lot of stuff uh
live shows are really popular as well
i've been to his live shows actually oh
really it's really it's really good
there's like a lot of psychology things
he basically like manipulates like
perception
yeah yeah yeah you know it's really just
interesting stuff yeah it gives you a
lot of perspective and
you know he he goes in saying you know
no all of this
is just magic you know like he a lot of
people not this is magic right
sorry so you said all of this is magic
so i'm just a [ __ ] magician you guys
know me hogwarts diploma right here
disney
no i i think cause like watch watching
his stuff he doesn't pretend to be
he doesn't pretend like he has powers or
something like that
it's all showmanship and that's
directions that british people like it
yeah yeah
but that's my favorite type of musician
magician
like uh [ __ ] um what are the what's
the favorite blind
no no david blaine the the uh penintella
that's what i like about pen and
television oh yeah yeah yeah we're not
[ __ ] magicians we're just good at
what we do
yeah yeah it's just all slider handshake
you know unlike you know [ __ ] like
chris angel who's like he's like yes i
am the second coming of christ i'm
literally [ __ ] dying
i literally died every now and then i
love going back
and watching like chris angel clips on
youtube just because like i remember
back in the day when i watched like
chris angel being like yeah i split this
woman in half and i was just like oh my
god this man isn't
he's actually he's like yes i'm walking
on water and it's totally not
just like see-through [ __ ] plastic
boards on the board